well I have a personal philosophy but I
am always trying to modify it I think
part of it the interesting thing about
being a historian is that you want to be
proved wrong I mean I want to see some
exception to a rule that I thought I
believed because that's the revelatory
moment I have no vested interest in
being consistent and if I think exactly
the same twenty years from now as I
think now the intervening 20 years will
have been a disappointment to me if I
felt that my objective was just to
verify my philosophy I would give up
tomorrow it's actually to falsify it so
let's let's start with what the
philosophy is now I was brought up and
remain an atheist but to be brought up
an atheist is very different from
lapsing from religious faith I've never
had any religious faith I have a
profound belief that as a basis for
ethical conduct the Ten Commandments are
pretty good and that actually the
monotheism's and particularly
Christianity offer a really quite good
guide to how to live well by well I mean
to live morally it's very hard for an
atheist to invent from first principles
a good ethical basis for behavior
because actually in the natural state
human beings don't behave well they're
quite strongly tempted to behave badly
and we're evolved in ways that that
actually encourage bad behavior
we're designed to kill strangers were
designed in fact to steal and so it's
very important that there should be an
ethical framework within which we live
and my dilemma is that I don't really
believe in any divine policeman or any
after that life payoffs but I do believe
that we should live well we should obey
some moral code
that we're not likely to invent for
ourselves so beyond that there are a
number of other important things that I
believe in I think I believe in the
truth of Darwinian evolution
I think I'm strongly attracted and
believe in Adam Smith's vision of the
free market as a superior mode of of
economic organization I'm strongly
persuaded by chaos theory about the
nature of the natural world and the
nonlinearities that are out there to
spoil the Newtonian party but I still
subscribe to Newton's laws of motion I
believe in all of these things and
they're my working assumptions because
as I said the son of scientists but not
a scientist myself I can't challenge
much of that I guess I take it on trust
but it does seem to me to hang together
reasonably well and for a Nestorian it
provides enough of a framework enough of
a framework to understand the natural
world to enable me to focus on what I am
interested in which is the way that
humans behave within that natural world
under the constraint that it imposes on
them so those are the things I believe
in what I don't have strong views about
are the motivations of human beings
themselves human nature seems to meet it
with a stuff of historical study and
although I'm probably instinctively a
Hobbesian in other words I think that
the state of nature is pretty ugly and
civilization is all about trying to rein
our natural impulses in I'm prepared to
be argued out of that in other words if
somebody can persuade me that in fact
human beings and matronly have a
preference for order and social
cooperation rather than killing one
another and that they're killing one
another is the exception rather than
norm then I will certainly listen and
and and be prepared to be convinced